I want to talk about a story that's not
being discussed very much in the United
States but it's actually making
headlines around much of the world
including Europe major protests have
broken out in Belarus and they've led to
hundreds of arrests four hundred by one
count with many people beaten Belarus
has put forward what's being called a
social parasites tax on underemployed
people of two hundred and thirty dollars
if you've been unemployed for six months
or more
many people are understandably furious
saying it's punishing people who might
not have a job because the economy is
bad right imagine that there's a bad
economy and that the individual is sort
of a victim of the bad economy the
government might be responsible at least
partially for the bad economy and then
the government is going to charge you a
tax because you weren't able to get a
job because their economy is a total
disaster thousands protested hundreds
arrested riot police came out
journalists covering the protests were
also arrested which it's a nice touch
when you when you want to really do a
full authoritarian crackdown on
protesting it's it's the cherry on top
when you start arresting journalists and
we've seen that around the world yeah
especially in Russia and I guess Belarus
now - this tax just doesn't make any
sense and I feel like anyone in any
school of thought would be opposed to
this because conservatives would say
it's punitive and liberals would say
it's going after the little guy so this
is something that can really only happen
in a dictatorship type form of
government it's big government in a way
but of course Republicans in the u.s.
they're probably some who would support
this by saying no because you got to
pull yourself up by your bootstraps and
if you're unemployed it's because you
don't you didn't look hard enough for a
job and you need to be punished for that
in some way a demonstrator Alexander
Ponomarev
told The Associated Press news agency
quote they are beating the participants
dragging women by the hair to buses I
was able to run to a nearby courtyard
the president insists that long term
they're going to keep this tax in
Belarus but it's been suspended for the
rest of this year and earlier this month
he had said that people who worked fewer
than a hundred and
three days a year would not have to pay
the tax this year and that those who
already paid it last year
would get a refund if they were to find
a job this is all just completely crazy
and according to a recent tax inspection
there's four hundred and seventy
thousand Bella Russians who should have
paid the tax only about 10% of that
fifty thousand actually paid it
according to Reuters it's all just so
absurd and crazy and even their ability
to enforce this seems to be lacking and
their president Alexander Lukashenko is
often looked at as the last dictator of
Europe yeah he'll have these press
conferences that go on for hours at a
time then he'll just berate the media
completely he always seems to get
reelected he's actually been in office
since I was five days old Wow so he's
the last European dick that's show he's
been in office for like seven years
yes that's crazy the government is
defending the massive rest and as Pat is
pointing out Belarus is unbeknownst to
many it doesn't tolerate what we would
call sort of peaceful typical dissent in
Western countries there are the typical
players we think of as far as cracking
down on dissent Belarus doesn't often
come to mind but they are and actually
have a little bit of a personal issue
that I'm currently having actually with
Belarus which is really there's this so
if you are so my mom's dad my maternal
grandfather was born in Poland and fled
Poland to avoid World War two and went
to Argentina and Poland has a provision
I guess you would call it or a rule of
law I don't know what it is where you
can get polish citizenship if you are
the direct descendant of someone who
left Poland because of being Jewish
before World War two right so in other
words because of my grandfather my mom
by that rule qualifies for polish
citizenship which is a EU citizenship
and then once she gets it I would be
able to get it so we did work around the
descendant of her exactly so we've been
working on this project and in working
on it with
Polish attorneys in the United States
going back and forth with their contacts
in Poland we determined that the part of
Poland that my grandfather is from used
to be Poland but now is actually Belarus
so that the paperwork that we need is if
it hasn't been burned if it exists it's
probably in Belarus the problem is there
which is the this was the funniest
understatement we were told by these
attorneys that were working with
diplomatic relations between Poland and
Belarus are not particularly smooth
right now which is obviously code for
good luck getting any of the paperwork
that we need from Belarus and this is
totally stalled I mean it's been two
years at this point and it would be a
really great thing to do i it seems like
it'd be a great thing to have an EU
passport why not right if it's available
to you but it's not going anywhere
because Belarus is just kind of like
yeah no we're just not helping you with
paperwork what paperwork we don't know
anything so anyway yeah that tangent
aside things are not good in Belarus and
we're gonna continue following what's
going on there today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30 day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com /t
DPS